Cameron's in San Francisco hi Cameron
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I've got a truck that I
need to get rid of mm-hmm $800 a month
dollars a month yep dadgum man what kind
of truck is this at the RAM 1500 sure
you got bad credit or something will be
interest rates
six and a half percent I don't think too
bad but now my credits pretty bad wow
you got slammed okay
yeah yeah you gotta get rid of this
thing that's a nightmare I think is
eating your lunch isn't it yes and the
real kicker is I'm about 7,000 under and
I can't get a loan to pay it off who's
the loan with Capital One no geez
they're gonna be no help okay
what do you make a year it up until this
point was about 45 and probably yell at
me for this one but I just put my two
weeks in last week why would you do that
I was in a pretty close call as far as
the car accident cuz on the job I Drive
for this and it just didn't seem worth
it to me at that point so what are you
gonna do for a living
I have my life insurance license so that
was kind of the goal as far as at some
point but at some point came quicker
than I was expecting or hoping over 25
well Cameron you need an income don't
you yep so what are you gonna do because
it's not the insurance license is it
you know think tough doubt it might be
you might be the one that does it but
very few people make a living in the
insurance business long term life
insurance sales turnover eighty percent
in the first year yep
so I mean oh do you do you live with
your parents yeah my mom my mother okay
so at least you're not gonna be homeless
and out of food right right
trucks gonna get repo'd if you don't go
get a job and this is going to get
really really ugly so I want you to go
get a job as soon as you can like by the
end of the day for your sake and then
let's get lit then work for jobs work
like a crazy person and then let's
scrape up the extra $7,000 and let's get
this thing sold out from around your
neck okay now but you keep I would say
I'll tell you in my life I've done a
whole lot of stupid things Cameron that
have cost me a lot of money and a lot of
pain and I have a PhD in D um b-but and
coaching people for 30 years on
financial things what I find is is that
way too many of us spend half our time
making up for decisions we made that
were done impulsively this truck was an
impulsive decision and walking in on the
job was an impulsive decision and you've
got to slow down on these decisions
you're getting hit your hammer and
yourself okay yeah slow down and
increase your level of wisdom by slowing
your speed down and just rethinking some
of these things that seem okay but I
mean you have no income give a $600
truck payment that you're upside down
$6,000 on and that situation is brought
on by two impulsive decisions buying a
truck you couldn't afford and walking
out on a job because you got scared
and you know those are those are not
well thought out wise moves in either
case I have done a lot Dumber things
than those two things that have brought
me pain too so I know what it's about I
understand the pain but what my heart
hurts for you because I think you're
facing some pain if you don't go create
an income now like for jobs and build up
the $7000 get yourself on a career track
get yourself out of this truck I'm sorry
you're facing all this but I've been
there myself I've done stupid stuff that
got me in a corner and it does get you
there